[Music]
travis is with us in louisville kentucky
hey travis welcome to the ramsey show
travis how you guys doing good man
what's up
hey i just got a quick question um and i
don't know how much you can give me
insight on it but we are trying to
decide when and if we should pull our
kids out of public schools and send them
to like a private christian school and i
just kind of wanted to get your uh your
view on that
okay um
the first thing is
you cannot permanently damage your
family financially for this
so this is an emotional subject
and i it can be bucketed for some people
in the same bucket of adoption
or
infertility treatment
or
going to a private school that has a big
name on it
like uh mit or harvard and they go it's
worth any amount of money to live your
life and hey hey and you start spending
like you're in congress okay right i
understand that you can't okay so you if
you you gotta keep away from those
emotions so a we're going to stipulate
you can afford it and then there's a
discussion to be had um my kids were
privates or were public school kids i
was a public school kid you were a
public school kid your kids are in
private school i was private christian
school oh you are yep oh and now your
kids are okay yeah uh so it is person so
let's let's just talk about this travis
can you can you afford this school that
you're looking at
yes i believe we can that's another kind
of a follow-up question that i'll go
ahead and do is my wife is a teacher
and uh she would be making the
transition also but they currently don't
have any uh permanent teaching positions
available so she would have to take on
what they're calling like a permanent
substitute role but they all they give
you know all employees of the private
school a discount on tuition once she
would become a teacher the tuition
becomes 50 off
yeah but 50 off of too much is just a
little too much right right i get it i
get it i just wanted to make sure you
were aware so you can afford it with the
50 off and with her cut in pay
current okay right yes
with her cut in pay
yes sir yes sir
because if they're cutting her pay a
hundred thousand which is not happening
and uh you're gonna you know
and you're gonna save ten thousand on
tuition that math doesn't work
right i know i get it she's gonna she's
they're only gonna cut the pay
as of right now we know because of the
substitute role once it gets back no no
no i'm talking about the school she's
leaving to the school she's going to how
much is her pay dropping
at the beginning it'll go from about 40
to around
25 i think okay she lost 15 grand how
much do you save in tuition
she'll save 50 of the
okay so you lost 15 but you gained 37
100 right it's still a pretty heavy loss
nothing to brag about yeah i i in this
situation travis i'd have her stay there
uh where she is or get another day job
until the position opens up full-time
position opens up at the private
christian school because
you're still going backwards you don't
need to the the pay cut
is a bigger deal than the than the
tuition cost for you of 7 500 bucks what
is your income
around around a hundred okay so you can
afford to send the kid for 7500. you got
one kid going
that would be two okay so fifteen
thousand out of a hundred you can do
that okay if and and she makes uh 40 and
so you make 140 000 income but i
wouldn't take a 40 to a 25 pay cut to
save 3 000 bucks or even 7 000 bucks
that doesn't come out it doesn't
unless she's just miserable and it's
part of her you know it's a move for
other reasons and those kinds of things
but we can talk about that as a side
issue anyway that's the math part of the
thing
and that that's kind of the foundational
issue for me now once you've said that
then then why do you move a kid to
christian school now what i will tell
you is this
i made the mistake our kids were in a
private christian school for two years
when uh when they were their very first
two years of school and we barely could
afford it i mean we were we were we
believed and we believed and we believed
and the mistake i made was my fault it
was not the school's fault and it was
not the christian education's fault it
was my fault was that i was so stupid
that i thought teachers and kids at
christian schools would all behave
that's a dumb assumption
they don't
some of the kids are actually better at
being sneaky
like ken coleman was okay oh
[Laughter]
that cannot be connected that cannot be
confirmed
school kid and a pastor's kid that's the
definition of sneaky folks this is
what's called fake news you just heard
dave said it's all fake news
yeah you know i am curious what is the
driving force if you're comfortable
sharing with us why this method um i
just i just you know i i don't want to
be too political sounding or anything
like that i just have we just have some
strong beliefs that a christian
education will be really beneficial to
our kids well you think the culture has
lost its dadgum mind and you're probably
right well yeah i definitely i
definitely do that yeah okay i agree
with you yeah
but what i want to challenge you one i'm
going to challenge you is is that it's
you're not going to escape that
you're still going to have to parent
them in this toxic culture oh yes yes i
agree and i was i that's the mistake i
made i'm not saying you're making that
mistake but i was like shocked that
i my kid comes home with cuss words and
i'm like where'd you get that i sent you
over there so you didn't get that
and that was dumb on my part
truth i was naive yeah
all right i understand that yeah i have
one of those can i ask you one other
question sure
okay so when she leaves there this is
her 10th year she's in her 10th year and
if she does leave and go to the the
christian school they don't have a
pension plan there obviously it's just
you know you like a regular 403 b i
believe
um
and so
if she leaves the school i'm not we're
not quite clear but if she left before
the school year is over this year she
might lose her small benefit of the
pension because once you have 10 years i
wouldn't i wouldn't make my decision
based on that i'd make my decision on
based on what's what's the right path
for my life don't let a little pension
like that dictate this there's more
important things here to consider
if i'm in your shoes
they've they're fed up with their
district big time aren't they
yeah they just they feel like they need
a haven
you know they got to get away it sounds
like something bad sounds like it's bad